[Music]
Yo, I had the image that hip-hop was something that young people did, and my
mother was surprised at the beginning that we were going to repeat
it.  It's not that we're there, we're just doing what we want to do
.
Music]
There are a lot of people who dance street dance, but there aren't many people in their
50s and above who dance in their bedrooms.
I think there's a reason why there's such
a thing as
being at that age.
When the two of us dance together, we put our feelings into it
, and we want to show that we can continue to sell our talents at this age and dance in front of everyone.
If I hadn't encountered dance,
I think my life would have been completely
different.I think dance has enriched my life.